Hello, and welcome to this intelligence squad podcast with me coming up,
we are recording this on November the 12th,
so that's just a week after the U S 2020 election.
I'm delighted to welcome our guests, Ruth Ben GAT historian,
and author of strong men. How they rise, why they succeed, how they fall,
Ruth. Hello.
Hi, thanks for having me on.
So Ruth, um, question number one.
Could you paint the like idealized strong man for
us? Like what, what does, what does kind of, you know, the, the,
the perfect strong man look like, you know, get that fees,
sexual appetites,
Stalin's enthusiasm for a secure code bureaucracy, you know,
w w w what, what, what,
what would you in your mind's eye see strong manners as perfectly Benning?
So I'm using the term, uh, and the, the, the,
the men in my book are all successful, strong men rulers. Um,
these, the 20th century ones for,
to refer to a type of authoritarian or authoritarian tending ruler
who, um, definitely exerts executive power destroys the,
or damages democracy,
but also has this kind of macho bluster and personal
relationships with, uh, other male despots often come to influence,
uh, national and foreign policy. And in general,
a strong man is somebody who exercises what I call a personalist form of rule
and his personal quirks character, financial needs, uh,
other such things, uh, come to dominate national and foreign policy.
He domesticates the judiciary, domesticates his party.
So the strong man is a man who is, uh,
highly seductive to many highly brutal, and these two things go together.
So w w what is the relationship between a
strong man as a kind of ruler and authoritarianism as a form of
government, are they, are,
they necessarily have to both be present in order for a strong man to truly be
able to exercise that kind of appetites and proclivities.
So the book looks,
I felt it was time to step back and look at a hundred years of
authoritarianism, and there are three phases. There's the fascist phase,
there's the military coup phase. So I've, Khadafi, there's,
Mabutu Pinochet in Chile.
And then there's what I call new authoritarians and authoritarianism kind of,
uh, evolves over a century and strong men rulers.
I see them as a subset of authoritarians there they're
always personalist rulers. And so, for example,
there were lots of military who into us during the cold war,
but peanut Shea and Sheila was the one who immediately exercised
personal power. Uh, you know,
patronage networks all depended on him.
So they're a subset of ruler,
but it also evolves over a century because today
authoritarians and strong men,
they get in by elections and they manipulate elections to stay there.
So the pioneer, there was barely scrawny in Italy who definitely, uh,
he never destroyed democracy, of course, but he controlled the media,
they own TV networks, and he ended up rapping, uh, the,
the state and the legal structure around his own financial and personal needs.
Hmm. You used a really, really interesting phrase, I think,
to describe the kind of opening of this third chapter in the kind of historical
epochs of strong man, you know,
and a liberal evolution of democratic politics. Um,
you, you chart the beginning of that, I believe as around 1990s, is that right?
And, and kind of,
what do you think began to happen then to kind of begin to usher us into this,
into this third phase where we're beginning to live through now?
I mean, it's the end of the cold war,
and I should say that because I'm looking mostly at, um,
people who destroyed or damaged a democracy,
I don't have communists. I'm not looking, I'm not looking at communist leaders,
so there's no style and there's no mile,
although there's a lot of attention when they influence right wing strong men.
So the end of the cold war allowed for the rise of a new right wing, um,
and a new phase of authoritarianism, but it's also a new phase of media.
And you get people who, again are,
there's fewer one party States today outside of communist, um,
countries like North Korea and China.
And so things evolve in a different manner. Um,
if you think of Putin and Edwin and Orban,
and over the time I've written this book, it took a few years to write the book.
Uh, many of those who are now ruling have consolidated their power, like Orban,
who now rules by decree, but they came in through elections, um,
and they,
it took them a while to come to amass this amount of power.
So today it's evolution and not revolution in the strong men world.
Well talking of elections,
I don't think that we can go any further without talking about the one we've
just had. And of course, Trump. Um, so,
um,
how neatly does Trump fit within this definition of a strong
man?
So I live in America and, uh,
one of the impetus for writing this book was in
2015 and 16.
I saw Trump start to have rallies with loyalty oath.
He started to threaten violence. Uh,
when he said I could stand on fifth Avenue and shoot someone. And of course,
this is the kind of threats that, you know,
both scenario made in Brazil and do territory made while they were candidates.
So I started to track Trump as a kind of strong men figure. And again,
you have the, you have Berlusconi who, uh,
was also a strong and figure in democracy. Trump is far more dangerous.
So what we're going through now, uh,
is the logical and very predictable extension of his behavior that he
set up very successfully, uh, doing his first term.
He's had four years, uh, to completely domesticate the GOP.
It's really, it's really his tool, his personal tool,
which has all the more, uh, astonishing because men like Bose Connie or,
or Mussolini, they formed their own parties,
or you think of Orban who they were.
They had a leadership role in their parties for many years.
Trump came from outside and he still managed to, uh,
have this loyalty code and this corruption, he, you know,
he made them co-conspirators. So they stuck with him through everything.
And the GOP is the conservative elite equivalent of those
groups who, uh, backed Hitler and Mussolini to come to power.
And so you always see these figures, these conservative elites,
these political elites. So what we see now is that he's refusing to,
uh, acknowledge the results of the election and his personality cult and his
propaganda machine have so far carried him through.
Well, I,
I thought we might use Trump as a microcosm to talk about the kind of three
phases in a kind of strong man's career, you know, the winning of power,
then the use of it, and then finally the loss of it. So, um, do you know, to,
to, to what extent then do you think kind of Trump capture of power, you know,
and I'm thinking, especially if the,
that fateful 2016 campaign and the way that he kind of built himself,
this kind of incredible kind of insurgent momentum to take on being convents
within rebel party towards scent,
is that kind of iconic and characteristic of the way in which strong men
normally catapult themselves into the kind of highest echelons of government.
So one of the things that, um, was truly, uh,
eye-opening to me was that, you know,
so the book is an attempt to show certain patterns in all of these
phases. Um, and it's actually an expo. The, the,
the body of the book is an exploration of the tools of rule corruption,
propaganda, machismo, incitement to violence or violence.
And so, again, things work differently in the 21st century for some aspects.
Um, Trump didn't have the violence that Maslany had,
but you have this dynamic where the outsider comes in and he's
clearly an extremist. He talks about in his case,
he talks about violence and he's let into the system by elites
who want to, for, they think they can use him,
and then he'll calm down. If he gets into government,
I call this the pivot delusion, or they call them a clown.
And they thought that they could tame him and use him. And this was, of course,
the fallacy with Hitler and Mussolini and even peanut chain chili,
although it was a coup,
there were Christian Democrats who supported him because they thought that he
would restore order, get rid of Ian,
did a socialist and then have a return to democracy.
And of course that was tragically wrong. So over and over again,
these men behave the same way. And one of the, uh,
very unfortunately for us in America and actually the whole world Trump's
personality, his,
his temperament maps on a hundred percent to those of ruler's past
the outcome is different today, but the aspirations and the, uh,
style of rule because of character, including the refusal to leave office, um,
is exactly the same.
And in terms of the use of power, then, um,
that a once a strong man is, is in power. Um,
I, you point to kind of propaganda and virility and corruptions as these main
major attributes. But, but I, I want you to talk about, um, spectacle,
because there seems to be this kind of incredible draw to spectacle that strong
man hat, you know, whether it's Trump's wall or Gaddafi is tent city, or,
you know, giant golden statues, why are they so drawn to it?
One thing I've found is that almost all of the men who have success,
cause there's lots of, you know, men who are around who are liberal figures,
but the ones who are success often have a background in
spectacle or media. Um, Mabutu uh,
was a journalist as well as Mussolini. Um, of course, Hitler, Hitler,
actually, maybe your listeners know this. Um, he, you know,
he was a very, he was a big fan of miscellany and he studied him very closely,
but Hitler couldn't get to power for a decade. You know,
he had his push and then he went to jail. So he took hypnotism lessons.
He took acting lessons and voice lessons, and he practiced his spectacle,
his gestures that became famous in front of a mirror during the 1920s.
So all of these men, and of course,
Beverly's Connie was the master of television.
And we have Donald Trump who is a real reality television star.
All of them are highly attentive to how they present themselves,
how they use their bodies and how they seduce followers.
So one of the things that was, you know,
the many red flags about Trump was his skill in, uh,
forging these bonds with his followers and their emotional bonds.
It's not just about obeying him. It's about making them feel part of something.
And this was the movement,
and this is buying him through this illegal, uh,
maneuvers he's trying to do now to discredit our election,
70 million Americans, more than that voted for him,
despite his criminal mismanagement of the pandemic.
And that is a Testament to his skill at staging these spectacles.
When you, when you think about, um, strong men,
how would you navigate this kind of strange dualism of like skill and
madness, because it seems that they, they, you know, you, you,
your descriptions of them both kind of recognize that, uh, dryness, uh,
being able to yeah, manage large populations and their own image and, you know,
exploit crises and act decisively. But at the same time,
it feels like almost exclusively,
the strong men that you deal with are literally insane at the same moment.
You know, there,
then I don't see them as insane that there are many of them are criminals,
of course, and, and come to a power with a criminal record.
And then if they're willing in a democracy, uh, like Berlusconi and Trump,
that governance becomes about, uh, damage control.
So we can differentiate those kinds of figures from, you know,
people who had one party dictatorships. Definitely one of the,
one of the things they do in the corruption chapter is look not only at their
financial con corruption, but how they establish this divided rule,
how they, how they structure their governance, uh,
in ways that allow them to have total power.
So that hiring and firing people constantly Kadafi, for example, he,
he was energized by chaos.
And so one of the macro themes, um, is that,
although we're led to think that authoritarianism is a productive
form of government, it's efficient, um, it's good for business. Uh, Trump,
you know, miscellany made the trains run on time, what I show,
and there are more and more studies coming out by economists on this is that
it's a highly destructive and chaotic form of government. Uh,
there's so much waste, not only human waste from, um,
from violence and people being prisoned,
but also the formation of large communities of exiles who are business owners
and other people who have invested in their country for decades and have to
leave the country. So there's capital there's capital flight,
there's all kinds of negative, um, you know, outcomes that,
that we've been too influenced by, uh,
American PR firms who work for authoritarians authoritarians own propaganda
to fully grasp the magnitude of this destruction that cause, and,
and here it does relate back to they're very, um,
they're very kind of irascible and impulsive temperament.
And so the book is an arc. It goes from their rule, their,
their ascent to power, but it shows how the,
in some cases they're their own worst enemies because the systems that they set
up are counterproductive and lead them to make bad decisions. And then, uh,
they fall.
Well, we're going to get to the full in a second.
Cause I think that's especially what we all have to deal with at the moment.
But, but before we do, I just wanted to briefly talk about crisis, um,
is that, that seems to have an especially important kind of role in the kind of,
you know, as a punctuation point of a tool in the, in the, um,
in the lives and careers of strong men, um, how important is it and,
and how worried should we be about,
about Corona virus now as being another opportunity for strong men across the
world? Not just Trump too, to kind of see this as a moment, which they,
where they can really extend power in ways, which they weren't able to before.
You strong men thrive on crisis, and it can be any kind of crisis.
And ideally they're helping to create a crisis and then they weaponize it and
exploit it to influence their power.
So whenever you see a one way you can think, well,
is this person there's a new politician on the scene?
Are they kind of a strong man type?
If they start talking about crisis politics and also their own victim hood,
um, and how their victim, but they're also savior, um,
both going to use to call himself the Jesus Christ of Italian politics because
of that. So they take the hits for the nation,
but they are also the only ones capable of saving the nation. And then every,
anything that goes wrong when they mismanaged things,
because it becomes a result of their kind of victimhood.
So when Corona virus hit,
it was very interesting to see the initial reactions of world leaders.
And so you had both Sinero and Trump,
who first tried to kind of deny it and saying it was like a little flu,
right. And try to make it go away, manipulate statistics.
And eventually Trump, just a Trump administration just gave up.
Um, and they said,
we're not going to even try and manage this and continue to have rallies.
And this was his ego need to have the rallies that,
that they are nothing without an audience.
And so Trump's need to be on the campaign trail and to keep the bond with his
followers far out, weighed his concern for public welfare.
So in the case of Trump, it's a very,
it's like a microcosm of all these dynamics. Um, and,
and truly the thing we need to realize about Trump is that, um,
because of Americans have never had a foreign occupation or dictatorship,
they've used a democratic framework to interpret Trump, and this is wrong.
Trump is not there to govern in a democratic sense.
He's there to make money for Trump organization.
He's there to build his personality cult and keep his followers.
And he's there to stay in power. And,
and idea of public welfare public goods is, is,
is completely alien to him. Hmm.
But this was the thing that confused me about, about the, the, the, this, the,
the kind of strong men reaction to Corona virus. Was that kind of,
if you look back at other crises, you know, like the Reichstag fire,
or what do I say is more contemporary already done in the Philippines,
they've kind of used crisis as a way of expanding the reach of government,
you know, emergency laws, more legislation, you know,
the deployment of military on the streets and so on. But that,
that isn't what say a bowl scenario or a Trump did with COVID. Was it, I mean,
like you would have thought that in a way the,
the obvious reaction would have been an extension of government, you know,
and an extension of the rain power into previously, you know, um,
kind of, uh, uh, contested spaces of people's lives, you know, or, um, kind of,
you know, places where government couldn't normally reach, but, but,
but it was a weird way that they kind of actually would drew government in a way
from, from the pandemic and its management.
Well, so we have to differentiate because there are, uh, uh,
very frighteningly,
there is a parallel process going on with the help of his ideal
co-conspirator William Barr, the department of justice,
who has completely politicized and purged the department of justice.
And they have been setting up, uh, since, uh, you know,
Trump's been doing this in 2018, setting up the whole structure to label any,
uh, civic descent, any protestors as terrorists.
And we saw during the summer in reaction to the black lives matter protests,
he sent in the military. Um,
there were people being bundled into unmarked cars.
Like it was people that's why people were talking about Huna does and peanut
check, and, and the GOP went, you know, along with this, in,
in great measure, uh, there was Senator Tom cotton who said,
let's bring in the military, you know, to turn the military on own people.
So they are extending government in ways that are very frightening. And I have,
I have zero doubt that if he were reelected, um,
we would see this extension of government in,
in ways that are very dire for journalistic freedoms and
for the right to protest the right to assemble. Um,
all of this infrastructure is being completed with Corona virus. It's really,
uh, Trump is not interested in devoting his time to good governance.
And so they'd simply gave up and indeed, uh, other, uh,
governance priorities,
like keeping his personality cult weighed more far more. And,
and yes,
this is destructive because he could have come out fairly easily
as, you know, no one could perhaps Tane Corona virus. We see in democracies,
they're in lockdowns again, but he could have done a much better job,
but he's not interested in doing that job. He's interested in other jobs.
Um,
we've spoken a lot about the kind of vulnerabilities of society to strong men
and authoritarian rule, but could you, could you talk a bit about some of the,
like resiliences, which society has? What, what, what,
what typically are the characteristics of societies,
which kind of can either reject or recover from,
from these kinds of power grabs?
So this was, uh, at times this was not a fun book to write.
Um, there was a lot of grim stories of, you know,
institutionalized racism and sexual abuse and all of this.
So when I got to the resistance chapter, it,
and there is acts of resistance,
resistance are in every chapter it's threaded throughout, but, um, it was,
uh, it was inspiring to see the forms of resistance and how over a
century. Um, there are techniques that continue, um, and,
and depending on the situation,
which each society can vary in the amount of policing that there is, but,
you know, small acts, um, sometimes resistance resistance is what you don't do.
Um, you, you don't, you don't do the Hitler salute.
You don't show up to the fascist youth group. Um, but many times, uh,
the core of resistance, even in our digital era.
And I look at how certain, um, key moments, synagogue,
cinematic, moments of resistance, where the police break down your door,
and you have to hide your documents nowadays, like in the 20th century,
we couldn't really see that because, uh, we didn't have social media nowadays,
like in Russia, when, when, uh, critics of Putin, you know,
the police come to their door, they're filming it and they're streaming it live.
And I recount, uh, one, uh, critic who, uh, filmed his, uh,
drone, carrying his hard drive out the window to a friend's house to save his
contacts.
So I try and have these examples in the book of how things have changed and how
things have stayed the same. And so the book,
each chapter goes over a hundred years and talks about a different, uh,
either instrument of rule like propaganda or the resistance chapter.
So,
but the core of resistance remains bodies coming together to reclaim
public space,
to speak back publicly to the ruler,
but also to his allies and also to foreign lenders.
And this kind of nonviolent mass protest is at the right time
when, uh, when, uh, uh, a leader is losing his power.
We have Belarus today as an example, um,
it's highly effective and there,
there are kind of rituals that can go on, um, that get recycled.
And this was very inspiring. Um, during the fall of communism,
there was a ritual called the Baltic way where everybody held hands across
several States and in 2019 in Hong Kong,
protesters revived this and paid homage to it by linking hands.
So, so I think, you know, the,
the reader will have a lot of sense of the range of resistance. Um,
and it's not, some is violent and the most effective has been non-violent.
We are going to come back to loss of power and Trump in just one second.
Cause I think people listening to this will badly want to know your thoughts
about how, um,
we can have a roadmap of sorts from history about what's going to happen next
and, and, and where it's all going to go.
But before we do that one final question about, um, you know,
resilience and Rumba vulnerability, you know, and that's around technology, um,
because we,
we seem to be faced with quite a kind of complicated story now about technology,
both in some cases kind of heralding and aiding despotism and
strong men and their culture personality, I suppose, particular. Um,
but then also of course being an absolute kind of endemic, um,
uh, kind of part of the story of resistance and protests. How,
how do you see that playing out now in terms of changing the kind of playing
field, um, upon which, you know, strong men, um, kind of operate.
Yeah. The big debate about whether, um,
digital media help or harm the strong men is,
is, is going to be ongoing. And, um, you know, for every time, uh, I mean,
obviously, uh,
rulers like Putin and Erawan have been extremely able in blocking, um,
you know, platforms that they very quickly that are going to do them damage,
but the resilience is in the workarounds that people find.
And you saw this in Hong Kong. Again, I don't talk about Chinese communism,
but Hong Kong where they, they w they, uh,
took advantage of Tinder or Apple's airdrop to get around, uh,
these platforms that, that were, that were banned.
So that kind of inventiveness will continue. Um,
but clearly when I, uh,
studied the story of Trump's rise and his use of Facebook,
and he actually used a kind of e-commerce model and the product was
Trump, and the, the means by which he, uh,
publicized his product was Facebook mostly. And I,
the reader will find the exact number here,
but tens of millions of ads were taken out by the Trump campaign
on Facebook versus about 60,000 by the Clinton campaign.
So the Trump was, was so savvy and using digital media,
and this is one, perhaps the only thing that Cushner, um,
got right, uh, and, and pushed for.
Um, so,
so Facebook and certainly Twitter have been a kind of,
co-author one could say of the Trump presidency, um, uh,
the, the Facebook in the ascendant phase, uh,
and Twitter in the maintenance of power and both Trump and both scenario
use their personal accounts. And when Trump leaves office, if he does,
he will retain that personal account and thoughtful retain
his S it's integral to his personality cult.
Well, coming now then finally, to Trump and loss of power, um,
how close has Trump got to
genuinely shaking the foundations of American democracy?
Because I guess th this is going to counter view here, which says, okay,
Trump did lots of really horrible things. Um,
he was certainly extremely populist.
He certainly himself doesn't seem to betray any great love of, of democracy,
but the basic institutions and the norms and the culture and this,
and fundamentally the separations of power within American government have
remained strong, and they will eventually be the things that get rid of Trump.
So, um, I would beg to differ a bit,
uh, with that because Trump has been successful, uh,
in politicizing the federal bureaucracy,
starting with the department of justice, the department of state,
there have been hundreds of thousands of civil servants who have left, uh,
and have been replaced by ideologues, by zealots,
by corrupt people who will do Trump's bidding.
And the number of judges Trump has appointed, uh,
hundreds of judges and every level we hear most about the Supreme court.
So there are statements from, uh, you know,
democratic senators and political analysts that talk about the
independence of the judiciary and the kind of independence of the three
branches has been badly harmed by Trump.
And in the case of the judges, uh,
it's going to take many years to recover this, and this is why, of course,
the conservative, the GOP. That was one of the things that,
that was part of the pact.
And also for evangelical Christians who have been very important. Uh,
so w we haven't begun to assess the damage that Donald Trump has
done to institutions to, again, the federal bureaucracy,
it's, it might seem a very boring topic,
but it's absolutely key to the implementation of policy,
to the imposition of a certain ideology.
So the office of civil rights,
civil rights used to mean a struggle for racial equity
for, for economic equity. Um, and now it, it's,
it's the, the official office of civil rights is about protecting the, um,
the rights of white Christians, um,
who shouldn't be in and trying to erase the separation of church and state,
and some of the men who are most influential and are now, uh,
colluding with this power grab like William Barr and Mike Pompeo, uh,
BARR is a Catholic with, uh, links to Opus, DEI,
and Pompei was an evangelical Christian, but they both, uh,
see the ideal form of government as one that, uh,
doesn't have much room for separation of church and state.
So I think that we underestimate Trump at our peril.
So thinking especially about the independence of the judiciary,
which I suppose is kind of a question,
which has never been more important normal rather than,
than really just about now. Um,
how confident are you that the kind of mechanisms of government and the
judiciary will eventually, and not eventually, I mean,
really quite soon kind of actually cause Trump to leave power.
Well, you know, that there's.
Various, you can gain this out in various ways. And one, uh,
one end point is the Supreme court gets involved and that's exactly why they
rushed through the appointment of Amy Coney Barrett, uh,
to have this majority. So, so in that, if it goes to that,
and then, um, he may be successful.
I'm not one of the people who were talking about coups.
I like to be as somebody who immersed themselves in coups for years and has the
whole third of the book is on cue, the era of cruise.
I like to be careful with my language, um,
but there is definitely an attempt to, uh,
illegally stay in power with, with the help of the judiciary.
And so now, um,
just as Trump's propaganda machine is waging psychological warfare on
Americans telling them that the election was illegitimate.
The judicial mechanism with bar at the head is trying to reopen
vote counts and claim that, uh, the other day he,
the DOJ said that, Oh, well, we can't decide the election.
I forgot what state it was because the votes are now under audit. So this,
this is where you go back to crisis, this creation of the,
of a period of prolonged crisis. Um, and, and then we'll,
we have civil unrest,
and then you have this parallel process of being able to use the
state, um,
to label protesters in the streets as terrorists and arrest them.
So there are many outcomes. I can't tell you where it's going to go,
but we can say that they've set up for every eventuality. Um,
and there's nothing that they won't do to try and remain in power.
Okay. Well, Ruth, my last question is about healing. Um, so,
so let's kind of assume that Trump is eventually ousted from
the white house, um, whether he admits the loss or not. Um,
of course the kind of rhetoric is kind of beginning to shift now towards trying
to begin to heal the kind of partisan chasms, which have opened up over,
over the law. Well, I mean, for, for, well, over a decade now,
how, how,
how do we begin if we are to see Trump as a strong man and therefore his
agenda is essentially being anti-democratic by its very nature.
How do we begin to kind of find common ground, I suppose,
with the 70 odd million Americans,
not to mention the many other people around the world,
but saw something in his message or something in his agenda. Um,
cause I,
I guess my worry is that if you see simply portraying him as a strong man
for any kind of small D Democrat kind of just creates basically a message that
we just have to resist and fight. Like there's no art, there's no other option.
So, so what other options are there for us to, to,
to try and find some kind of way of,
of moving closer to people on the other side of the aisle.
So I'm assuming he leaves and then we can have
turn the page. And of course, the way that Biden is being,
which is kind of low key, decent, not giving into this panic,
not embracing the crisis, we fight you,
but being a common assurances that he will be C, C,
he will be in government, you know,
and at the end of January are just what we need.
Cause people are very exhausted, but I actually,
I end the book on a really hopeful note, um,
that could even seem Pollyannish to some, uh,
about the importance of love and the various platforms
of, uh, uh, in, in [inaudible] Turkey, uh, emo blue, who,
who ran, who successfully won, uh, as mayor of Istanbul,
had a platform of radical love to combat populist polarization
and reaching out to the other side has never been more important.
And I'm an admirer of, uh,
Pete [inaudible] who goes on Fox news every single day
and talks to them. And he is able in his way,
he is a veteran, um,
he's able to reach them and we don't really have another choice.
I think one of the last sentences of the books that if,
when you're at a crossroads, you either turn away from each other,
which is what men like Trump want,
or you try and build bridges.
And if you're going to be a functioning nation,
a productive nation and you're going to heal, uh, and again,
this polarization started well before Trump.
He just weaponized it there's really no other option. Um,
so that's how I conclude the book with examples of people from, uh,
Edwin's Turkey and Putin's Russia who are coming around to the same
way of thinking. And I think that we need to, uh,
apply this in the States as well.
Well, uh,
radical of what better place than that to leave such a great discussion. Ruth,
thank you so much. Um, this has been so eyeopening and,
and truly revolutionary, um,
I'm commenter and you've been listening to intelligence squared.